If you would've told us in 2011 that the third
sequel in the Thor franchise would be the
one of the funniest movies of the year on
its release, there wouldn't have been a lot
of reason to believe you.
Yet here we are, with Thor: Ragnarok earning
over $120 million on its opening weekend,
and rave reviews crowning it as the most hilarious
entry in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
One of the best comedic moments in the entire
MCU occurred during The Avengers, a movie
which, apart from the Iron Man series, was
really the entry in the franchise that proved
Marvel's heroes to be as deft with their comedic
timing as they were with landing punches.
We're talking, of course, about Hulk vs. Loki,
specifically when the green guy absolutely
thrashes the cocky Asgardian god …
"Puny God."
Trailers for Thor: Ragnarok teased the reunion
of Loki with Hulk, the only Avenger who can
be said to have truly—and humiliatingly—defeated
him.
But while the two do team up by the movie's
end, Thor: Ragnarok was originally supposed
to address their contentious relationship
in a more direct, hands-on way, with a hilarious
callback to The Avengers that reportedly had
test audiences howling.
According to Empire, there was originally
a moment near the end of Thor: Ragnarok where
Hulk, Thor, and Loki all line up beside each
other before Hulk, still harboring no love
for Loki, unexpectedly punches him out of
the frame.
The callback actually served a dual function,
referencing Hulk and Loki's past encounter
while mirroring a similar sucker punch Hulk
once pulled on Thor.
Director Taika Waititi says viewers loved
the moment, but it was ultimately cut for
the purposes of time.
Evidently, it made people laugh a little too
hard, derailing the momentum of the scene.
Waititi explained the content of the missing
scene to Empire.
"They all land on the bridge—Thor, Loki
and then Hulk.
They stand for a second.
Then Hulk just smashes Loki, punches him out
of the frame—just like in Avengers, when
Hulk did it to Thor.
It was a crowd favorite, but we just had to
get rid of it for time.
It might be on the DVD."
Get your laughs in now, because when Avengers:
Infinity War hits theaters, it won't be a
lighthearted romp... that's for sure.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!